なにその顔？
よろこんでるの?
こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーと
カリ...
あのーー
卓球したいなと思いまして
卓球台を買いました!
おい
多分なんですけども
なんで笑ってるんすか
一人暮らしをしてるわけなんですけども
一人暮らしで卓球台を買う人ってそういないと思うんですよ
んー。まぁいないでしょ
いつでも卓球をできる環境を整えたいので
それをね、ちょっと
設置して
今から家に
今日は、純粋に
あの、個人的に楽しいやつです
なるほど
普通に遊ぶやつ
そう
普通に家で卓球楽しみたいので
やりたいやりたい
では行こう
シュッ
はい。卓球台が届きました
国際規格の卓球台ということで
なんでこれ買ったの?
みんながね、ガチの卓球できるように
なんか、本物の卓球台をちょっと買っちゃったので
上まで持って行こうと思います
よし、行くぞー
せーの
あいあい
ちょっと待って
ほんとに重いやつだこれ
これヤバいぞ
のった
あ、電気消えた
これきつくね?
ちょっと...無理かも
えーどうしよう
バラす? (分解する?)
すいません
ちょっと、家の都合上入らないので
バラしてから上に持ってきます
いや白猫の音するなよ
この状況でゲームしてんすか
あーもう一個
よいしょ
これギリギリだなー
おーけおーけー
まとめて運ぶのは無理だったので
これをもう一個運んできます
行こう
せーの
わっしょい、わっしょい、わっしょい
ターン入ります
入ります
あれ、これカメラ?
カメラ
カメラ移動はいりまーす
カメラOK!
おっし、おっし、おっし
カメラ、カメラ待ってください
カメラ入りました!
はい、というわけで無事
卓球台を二つ分運べたので
卓球台を作っていこうと
思います
まずは
キャスター入ります
ネット!
声ちょうだい
声ちょうだい...
早送り
はい出来ました!
六角(レンチ)取って
嫌だー
嫌なんかいー
早送り
ねえ待って待って
デカ!
ヤバいな
でかくない?
もう、俺ん家場所無いんじゃない?
はい、というわけで卓球やっていこうと思います
いえーい